the only Victor from the open section
Sam Sean is with us Sam welcome to the
show this was a tenis game great opening
preparation but I have to say Ray found
some really good moves that you were not
aware of or at least it felt like you
were not aware of tell us your story
about this
game yeah so uh I surprised him with the
French today and um he probably didn't
expect it but I think he's played this
line so many times in his childhood that
he kind of recalled some really
interesting ideas or maybe he found this
interesting idea with Rook B3 and then
Knight D1 mhm uh I wasn't sure if I
played Queen C I played Queen C4 really
quickly but I wasn't certain if that was
the right move it is the best move
according to the engine yes it is the
best move okay yeah and then he played
this Knight D1 and I just simply didn't
like my position and he he he has a very
easy game he puts a night on E3 Pawn
goes to C3 yeah uh yeah I mean it might
just be worse for black and obviously
when you play the move Bishop to E7 you
probably understood that this is not
going the right way yeah things are not
going well yeah yeah yeah and after
Knight to E3 in fact the only move to
keep the balance was Queen to C8 but
already a lot of I definitely I should
have I should have found Queen C8
because the queen on C7 there's always
these tactics with Bishop G5 Knight
takes D5 I just shouldn't have allowed
that I mean Knight takes D5 with the
queen on C7 yes yes right right I maybe
bishop G5 is not the best move but it's
at least you know here it doesn't even
work uh KN takes D5 yeah yeah so so I
mean I was just basically trying to
survive for as long as I could Bishop B5
uh H5 uh A4 was a decent move Rook B6
Bishop C6 and here I think uh I mean
queen D3 I thought he would play Just
threatening Queen G6 and then Rook H6
just pick up the
pawn uh on A6 mhm I it's just a
risk-free Advantage for w probably
winning not not like decisively winning
but it's it's definitely a winning
position for w yeah yeah it it was C
move but uh Queen to C2 by the way was
very decisive at this point Rook H6 with
the same idea of Queen G6 and
C4 uh and this one is ah yes now I don't
even have Rook f8 yeah and if I go Rook
f8 after Queen C2 yes probably you have
to do that but after Queen G6 and Rook
to B2 you're just more or less Stu yeah
this is just it's just it's just
horrible yeah and I have the idea of
Knight G2 Knight F4 well yeah yeah this
is if if you see Knight G2 you just play
this with the game's over yeah yeah yeah
but you got a second chance and you made
the best out of it I have to say this
position yeah because uh this position
was uh I think what he missed was if
Queen D1 instead of Queen
E2 which is I think the most natural
move I play Rook takes F2 mhm and then
whatever he takes with I just play
Bishop C5 that's right and I just
survive here that's right Queen takes H5
King E7 yep and I think he has nothing
better than a draw y uh no that's so
once I saw this I was already starting
to feel a lot of confidence in the
position because I mean dead lost and
now suddenly I have a lot of Hope and
yeah when he played Queen to I was like
okay now I could even play for a win
after this queen2 queen C1 and you're
starting to take over for sure at this
point and uh it was this moment Queen 2
F5 yeah uh I was proud this queen F5
idea yeah yeah because I because the
position is probably holdable for what
if I don't play Queen F but this is so
tricky you King G2 King G8 uh in fact
after King G8 you're
winning it's just winning well this is
over yeah yeah this is over the way you
played it you conducted the attack you
finished the attack perfectly after that
congratulations Sam big big victory with
the black piece is how important it is
to get a victory in the first round with
the black
pieces I mean it's extremely important
especially when you have more blacks in
a tournament uh and I mean this
tournament is so strong every Point
really matters so yeah I'm very happy
with how the second part of the game
went guys
our congratulations uh Sam get your rest
and we'll see you
tomorrow thank you absolutely a very uh
deserved